l'accès à la santé est un droit pour
tous majeur vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure la force de notre système de
santé et de pouvoir répondre à cet
engagement je souhaite faire écho
aujourd'hui au cri d'alarme des
pharmaciens et des patients sur les
ruptures d'approvisionnement en
médicament qui se multiplient et qui
sont une des sources de dégradation de
notre système de santé sur le site
internet de l'Agence nationale de
sécurité des médicaments la liste de ces
produits s'allonge dangereusement les
ruptures d'approvisionnement des
pharmacies durant au moins une semaine
ont quasiment doublé depuis le début de
l'année passant de 6,5% à 12,5% du
nombre de références monsieur le
ministre nous sommes en crise sanitaire
os de la demande mondiale crise
énergétique bien sûr guerre en Ukraine
mais le vrai problème et la
désindustrialisation tout comme la
fixation par la France de prix trop bas
qui ne permet plus aux industriels de
fournir des médicaments courants de
façon régulière le résultat des milliers
de malades qui ne peuvent plus se
soigner ces situations de pénurie ou de
tension concernent des centaines de
références dont des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeurs comme
des chimiothérapies ou encore des
médicaments pour le diabète de type 2 et
peuvent entraîner l'interruption ou le
report du traitement d'intérêt vital et
ça c'est inacceptable alors Monsieur le
Ministre ma question est la suivante
comment en sommes-nous arrivés là
comment la mise en place en 2021 d'un
stop national de 4 mois n'a-t-elle rien
fait pour empêcher la dégradation
continue de la situation merci